I know where Jason Lakhan 4 is because
it put the tweet up here put the tweet
up moments ago we just saw the street
for the first time the tweet goes up
that prayers up for at Jason locking for
this is from a Twitter site called
Buffalo rumblings who just took a Josh
Allen pass off the leg hope nothing is
broken
Jason Locke and foreign of CBS sports
are you in one piece I'm good I'm good
yeah my phone and all the stuff in my
head so I look back there in my soccer
days and tried to trap it took it off
took it off the cat's rich but we're all
playing in a little thing it's training
if it's good for the soul so did you rub
dirt on it
so yeah it's fine it really wasn't that
bad route it wasn't it wasn't that bad
oh so wasn't he honestly I wrenched my
ankle and a pothole in front of the
Bears but still I'm in that Browns
facility yesterday so compared to that
this is nothing is that a metaphor for
anything Jason you know it could be my
life's falling apart it could be the
[Laughter]
good long no Jason I just figured you
know what you can go to the Wawa just
drown your sorrows and a bunch of Utz
chips it'll be alright at some point you
know okay so you're you are in bills
camp right now is what I'm leaving bills
camp on my way to Detroit to see the
lines next I am I'm done with the pills
okay so what did you see from Josh Allen
except a ball that hits your your leg
not much in terms of with the starters
is he by my count had five reps on 1111
with the one first one he was a decoy
and RPO from like the 12 yard line and
then they ran it inside and off 10 he
attempted a pattern in the end zone from
the 8 that got broken off there was
nothing there on a hole out so he
printed it for what I guess would be
considered a score and then he handed
off on an interest and that was it
a lot of work with the threes but the
freezer
young I mean he's surrounded by will
keep their and no one seems in any sort
of rushed you know and I don't blame
them frankly to make this all about
September or certainly not all about
July or August this is the same
organization that kept their eyes on the
prize last year even though the Seastone
well today I want to get a look at their
training or high right place
it's a baby rate that like to sort of
pick up um point course in real time
don't like that don't really out the
roster they P to get where they
ultimately want to go and I think
they'll take that same approach with
Josh mallet you know we're not going
beautiful we don't have our team ready
this year and we're probably a year or
two away as we talk too much there is
right now and we're not overloaded with
Bill guy and why you know why do we have
to you know what why does it have to be
about we seek one for Josh Dallas why
can't it be about how much he can do
this week and trust me it's only gonna
be five to seven reps today with the
large moon for a while and then if he
has some possible performances in the
preview so maybe they adjust and he gets
a little more in the Karen just a little
fast but takes experiment seems to be
the guy there right now oh gosh Wow
so it's not AJ McCarron what their five
days into this but being there today a
ball for the work was the peeterman team
for both the Deaf he seems to have a
handle on things well and and you know
you got to remember I mean guys betrayed
for so there is that's why right now you
know traded for tea for it who who
traded you know spitting me walk it's
like I'm not necessarily gonna get
wrapped up and what people think of what
they're doing right now it's all about a
bath to plan I get that today that's a
second first upstairs it's going to be
much more sort of game ready and they're
much more willing to make him the day
one quarterback of their defense and I
think Josh Allen will be poised to be
the day one you know week one
quarterback of the Rafah Jason Lakhan
four of CBS sports joining us here on
the show so when you were in Cleveland
it just seems it's all hunky dory that
Baker Mayfield was tasked to get an RV
for the quarterbacks by Drew Stanton and
Tyrod Taylor the tie-rod is is playing
the mr. chips role even though he wants
to take the the reins of this offense
there's no question about that but
Baker's balled out and the opportunities
that he's had how do you think I guess
that situation and just quickly handicap
the rest of the rookie quarterbacks so
far in camp and what you think it's
gonna look like week one in a month oh I
don't I don't think I mean I don't I
don't think there's any way Baker made
scales on that field anytime soon it
games that that count there's just again
there's not a pressing need to they
everybody loves what he's doing but they
really really love with I rod Keller's
Dilla that Baker's in the building
really early but like I want southern we
don't like tie rods in the building at
5:00 a tie rod the natural born leader
and tie rod is obviously it's infinitely
more experienced in the pro game that
Baker Mayfield and they haven't won a
game on a Sunday there and like three
here whatever two and a half years I
think they got a charter win football
games they have a pretty daunting
schedule early on and as much as
publicly everybody will sort of talk
about you know how great Baker is and
all that and here when you talk to
people privately and I talk to me if
they I love you did he's done nothing
but show us you know the best time so
far but there's no bleeping way he
thought of play for us at seven nine
Mike you know we can win some football
games we got to establish the different
culture here and we got a player best
quarterback and that's what I expect
them to do I mean that may be all well
and good Jason but and I know that you
know that it's a long-term play I get it
then why the hell do you do not drafts a
qualm Barkley and and and go and win
football games now with Tyrod Taylor you
love him so much I mean this group but
doesn't mean II have to play one and
they like job and uh look you could have
done a lot of if you want to if you want
to have a discussion about the assets
that were that first and fourth pick and
not having it often for chow
or not taking job or not taking planking
Berkeley and why they took Ward so high
and if you're thinking you're running
back at all one I think the best one
right off the board I'm not going to
argue any of that with you but given the
construction of their rocker right now
and where they are and how high rock
well how I mean not always like you just
at some point you gotta win football
games right but you've got to use the
best players you have in real time to
win a stake in football game before
you're ever gonna crawl out of this
colossal oh no I'm frankly this Baker
Mayfield I mean is it really start of
him to bear the sins on 1 in 31 you know
I mean week one going against the Ravens
or the Steelers yeah you know did that
is that the best environment for him
even if he does everything qqp boy I
don't know that that's fair no III hear
you and and and I think look a tie rod
balls out and they start winning
football games and then they're in that
tough position of well when do we turn
the page to Baker Mayfield is that when
we do because we did get him first
overall I guess then that's that's a
great problem to have and the same thing
with anybody that doesn't start a
quarterback that they just drafted do
you think Rosen ends up getting the
start for Arizona week one when they get
out there against um let me see you they
play in Arizona do you think you get out
there and week one with Josh Rosen I
against the skins I I don't think I mean
I don't know any other and I think well
Marge actually sees the field first
could if you made me just one who could
I would just Rosen just because you know
the next Sam Bradford getting to six
weeks without picking something up is I
mean the odds were saying there's a
chance
something may happen in a preseason game
or in a practice and I think Rosen on
this group was the most Pro ready and
you know I I could see that but I think
you'd have to be out Bradford and Brad
would probably have to get hurt I just
have to look you know really bad in the
preseason otherwise I think turn the
same boat as everybody else I don't
think any of a large active field
times or whatever you know in week one
and that one plays out do defeat what
lasts a couple for you here Jason before
some quick hitters sort of like a Josh
Allen pass off your leg some quicker a
Dez Bryant what's his scoop I was just
in Cleveland I know they talked
internally it's very signs about
bringing of it but I was all day faith
so over to him and as if it plans to do
so and the latest shuffle Twitter
probably it helped us call upon him I'm
waiting for content et because what the
money is going to be negligible without
the opportunity he might as well wait
somewhere where they have an
accomplished quarterback baby
springboard back that what's the scoop
with Khalil Mack not even a conversation
going on that could be that had on that
concrete potential him something it he
just tuck in he gets really suck it so
stay tuned on that one I don't think
freighters to the far right quick unless
they make you know and let they put just
you know top of the market money in
front from me and money like we've ever
seen Errol Thomas what about him Jason I
think you suck as well I think he feels
like there is money for him but it's not
it's Seattle and with given what these
accomplished in this week it was a
turning this week and given where that
franchise is right now sort of Pretoria
tinkering with things out I think he's
inclined to wait it out and hope that
that leads to a tree somewhere where
they're willing to get you know top of
the market plenty but certainly he get
all four years somewhere else and Erin
Donald mean August seventh on the web
you know he doesn't report by August 7
system with 30 days then he was arrested
playing fifties and it's still being
shuffled three or three P so on the Rams
I found a pic look we may not get you 20
45 or whatever but here's more than a
top of the Sudan at first pre cares and
misses on the table is the longest tick
and then it's not and then you know call
the play for
you know this contract we'll see where
it goes and call his bluff okay here we
go
I thought upon this day I could
understand what they accomplished put
that holdout and you know I would I
would make them prove to me just how
[ __ ] he could be I'm going to make
them the highest paid defensive player
in the history of the game but clearly
what they have out there is not yes it
is liking and I don't know about bidding
against myself this year given the fact
that you gave away the truth either left
Jason do you the man will chat soon
before the season safe travel you guys
at Jason locker for of CBS Sports the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience